ibm's acquisition of a robotic process
automation provider the release of ibm
cloud databases for enterprise db
and the 2020 top rated awards from trust
radius all
on this episode of ibm cloud now hey
everyone i'm ian and i'm excited to
bring you the latest and greatest news
and announcements
from ibm cloud recently ibm announced a
definitive agreement to acquire
brazilian software provider of robotic
process
automation informally referred to as wdg
automation
the blog link below has the full company
name in portuguese
with this acquisition we plan to bring
wdg automation's
rpa and ai driven chatbot capabilities
to two areas where enterprises have
critical automation needs
transforming business processes and
managing i.t operations
the acquisition will strengthen our ai
infused automation platform making it
one of the most fully equipped platforms
for cios and ceos looking to
quickly transform and standardize
business and it operations for growth
efficiency and resiliency ultimately
the plan is to include rpa capabilities
across the ibm cloud pack family
starting with the cloud pack for
automation for business processes and
the cloud pack for multi-cloud
management for it operations
for more information about this exciting
announcement please read the blog linked
in the description below
we'll also be holding an ask me anything
webinar with mike gilfix
vp of offering management for cloud
integration on july 15th
so make sure you register next up we've
got the release of ibm cloud databases
for enterprise db
edb postgresql advanced server joins a
broad suite of database technologies on
the ibm cloud databases platform
it's a fully managed production ready
database as a service
built from the ground up for scale and
security of enterprise workloads
modernizing your data with databases for
enterprise db enables you to save costs
gain efficiencies and power innovation
for new applications
the new release provides compatibility
with oracle offers a boost of
productivity and increases security
hit the link in the description for a
full rundown of all the features and
info on how to get rolling with
databases for enterprise tv
and finally i wanted to close out this
episode with a little bit of celebratory
news from the trust radius 2020 top
rated awards where ibm cloud has been
recognized as a leader in several
categories
the trust radius top rated awards are
the industry standard for unbiased
recognition of b2b
technology products and they're based
entirely upon customer feedback
since our customers are our top priority
and these awards are based on their
unfiltered feedback
we are thrilled that ibm cloud bare
metal servers ibm cloud object storage
and ibm cloud virtual servers won in the
is category
additionally the ibm cloud kubernetes
service one in the container management
category
and ibm cloud databases one in both the
database as a service and relational
databases categories
a sincere thanks to each and every one
of our customers who submitted reviews
because your feedback shapes what we do
if you'd like to learn more about trust
radius or the awards including the
criteria and ibm scores
see the link below thanks for joining me
today for this episode of ibm cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and of course please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now